The editors of Science Robotics have chosen
the most exciting robotic technologies for 2018.
Here are just some of the big innovations from last year
A new video of the world's most dynamic humanoid
show’s Boston Dynamics’ Atlas jumping
over a log with one leg, and bounding up increasingly
higher wooden boxes without breaking pace.
These feats add to walking on challenging terrain,
lifting and manipulating objects,
and executing a backflip like a gymnast.
For this latest parkour-type behavior,
the control software uses the arms, legs, and
torso to manage energy.
Atlas also has a novel visual sensing system
to judge each leap.
Although these behaviors are not achieved for all trials,
the demonstrations serve as an inspiration
for what robots can do in the near future.
This tailless flapping robot is a perfect example
of bioinspired design—
design that helps both to develop new technologies
and to unveil the secrets of how
nature builds living things.
Surprisingly, this bot can accurately reproduce
the rapid escape maneuvers of fruit flies
even with no explicit control of all its rotational axes.
And although it is over 50 times the size of a fruit fly
and does not mimic the wing morphology
or kinematics of any specific natural flyer,
it shows that the bot can serve as a physical model
to test how flying organisms control flight.
The editors consider it a paradigmatic example
of “science for robotics and robotics for science”
and expect that it will advance the development
of all flying robots.
This year we saw a self-assembling DNA origami
structure that can be moved precisely by externally
applied electric fields.
That means nanoscale DNA robots
can be controlled by a macro-level switch.
Molecular robots like these can be used for
transport of molecules or nanoparticles over
tens of nanometers and open the door to
programmable synthesis and assembly of materials
from the bottom up.
If you need an exoskeleton to help you move,
you probably don’t want it to be as heavy
as Iron Man’s.
A new light-weight, stretchy exosuit
offers new ways of integrating fabric design, sensing,
robotic control, and actuation to increase the wearer’s
strength, balance and endurance.
And human-in-the-loop control allows better
integration with natural movement.
The return of Aibo,
first introduced nearly 20 years ago by Sony,
brings increasing awareness of the role
social robots can play in childhood learning
or as companions for the aged.
Understanding the perceptions, interactions,
and expectations of the people around the robot,
and developing robot behaviors and personalities
that are context aware
are key challenges of social robotics.